[Music]
the first time in the history of the
academy awards and all black producing
team is being recognized
in the most prestigious category best
picture
judas and the black messiah that's about
the death of illinois black
panther party chairman fred hampton at
the hands of the fbi is up for one two
three four five
six oscars thank you very much the
producing team behind the film includes
charles d king he's a former top talent
agent cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller shows us
how king is working to transform
hollywood by redefining the power
brokers who decide which stories get
told
and who tells them do you consider
yourself a disruptor
i consider myself to be a positive
disrupter if nothing else 51-year-old
charles d
king is a change agent
he worked his way up from the mail room
to become the company's first black
partner
after nearly two decades at the talent
agency
now known as william morris endeavor
he represented some of the biggest names
in the industry
but in 2015 king left to launch his own
production company
you come all the way back you
macro aims to not only produce but also
finance projects driven by people of
color
this content that we see it has a huge
impact both positively
as well as negatively and i want to make
sure that we're part of the sea chain
of seeing images that represent the
spectrum of who we are
it's not easy for me to admit that i've
been standing in the same place
for 18 years i've been standing with you
the company's first major studio release
was fences which went on to earn four
academy award nominations
i'd say when denzel started winning
awards and viola was
started winning and they were
acknowledging macro
and so i think things really began to
run from there
what is your vision our vision is to
build a global media company so think
disney
think dreamworks but that have people of
color at the center of them
a ucla report found that people of color
bought at least
half of the tickets for nine of the top
10 films in the u.s
in 2019 and while diversity on camera is
on the rise
researchers say that more than 90
percent of senior executive positions
are held by white people we need people
who can not just make quality films but
also who can determine what gets made
and so that takes financing journalist
pamela newkirk has been reporting on
diversity in business
for decades i think part of the problem
in the past has been that we look at
films as either african-american films
or latino films or asian films
and i think charles has a broader vision
he's looking at
people of color writ large what are you
doing
fixing your headache in just six years
macro
has been behind popular streaming shows
and more than a dozen movies
including judas and the black messiah
the black panthers
are forming a rainbow coalition king
believed in the project enough that part
of the film's budget which was reported
to be north of 25 million dollars
came from his own company having that
co-financed
deal what did it provide you with
provided me with a seat at the table in
another scenario
three four years before i don't know how
the movie would have gotten made not in
the way that we made it
and how did you make it we made it
unapologetically
we made it telling the truth that
creative freedom left the door
wide open for first time studio director
shaka king
had this gone through more traditional
means in the sense of you know
having no financing attached i think it
would have been a harder sell
what kind of tweaking do you think they
might have made it would have probably
had to lean
far far far more commercial i have no
idea but i wouldn't have done it
so you know like it just
it would never have happened all this
talk of diversity though is
still a struggle to get films like this
made
yes thank you for being honest
[Laughter]
we still will go into pitch meetings
where there isn't a single single person
of color in the room
still king says he's encouraged by the
direction
hollywood is heading and i think it's
the combination of that
of storytellers who are getting access
of more of us with inside of the studios
and the streaming platforms that have
decision making power when you have more
of that
you have options i believe that will
create more of the sea
change within our industry
[Applause]
for cbs this morning michelle miller
los angeles
yeah i'm mesmerized by daniel just in
that clip again yeah it's an amazing
film
charles d king a round of applause
listen a positive disrupter and a badass
yeah
i like his vision though what he says
think disney dreamworks
why not macro and money absolutely money
talks and put his own in to get more
control and he's so right to show
images that represent the spectrum
that's been part of the problem in
hollywood it's been so
there have been so many stereotypes many
of them very negative but for him to say
i want to show
the spectrum and there is a spectrum
over categorizing
exactly oh yeah it's like they're
american films they're not necessarily
blacks or asian films they're american
films